METE ATAMEL: Let's
deploy an ASP.NET Core
app to a Kubernetes cluster
on Google Container Engine.
First, in Cloud Shell,
create a Kubernetes cluster.
As cluster is setting up,
create an ASP.NET Core web app.
Restore and publish the app
to get a self-contained DLO.
Inside publish folder,
create a Dockerfile.
Dockerfile builds on
the official Google
image for ASP.NET Core apps.
Build local image using
Google Container Builder.
This publishes the image
to Google Container
repository that we can use from
our Kubernetes cluster later.
Finally, create a Kubernetes
deployment with the image
and expose it to
the outside world.
In a few seconds, your app
will be running in Kubernetes.
Thanks for watching.